hello there how good is your knowledge
about fortnite's story today i have a
quiz for you a bunch of trivia all about
fortnite live events and the storyline
be ready to pause the video if you need
any more time to think about your
answers please leave a like if you'd
like to see this become a series and
let's see who knows the most about
fortnite battle royale let's do this
[Music]
question 1 the unvaulting event let's
start easy back in chapter 1 season 8 a
mysterious vault opened up underneath
our feet under loot lake we all jumped
inside and we could vote for one item to
be unvaulted which item won that vote
[Music]
yes of course it's the drum gun all the
casual players of the world united and
unvaulted the drum gun to cause
unbelievable pain to fortnite
competitive players
yo everyone's hitting the drum gun no
one's on the bowser i come over here
you bots
question two the device in chapter two
season two midas built a secret doomsday
device underneath the agency an
unreleased loading screen showed us his
new power suit known as cyclo there is
actually a secret character hidden on
this loading screen can you find them
and who is it pause the video if you
need more time
did you get it it's jules and she's
hidden in the reflection in the glass
she's tough to spot but she is there
jules is the daughter of midas and an
accomplished engineer we're expecting to
see her and her dad in the fortnite
story again very soon question three the
final showdown this question comes from
nikkei 30. after the mech defeated the
devourer she flew into space but what
did the mech do before leaving you have
two options here did it floss then
salute or salute then floss
you got the answer well this happened a
floss then salute the one-armed flossing
emote was added to commemorate the
victory of the mech no sweat and now
thanks to a lobby screen we know the
mech flew all the way back into space to
a secret moon base and it isn't looking
in great shape
question 4 the butterfly event this is a
simple one you may struggle with where
did the butterfly event take place what
was the name of the poi are you ready
it's leaky lake loot lake was drained
when kevin rose up leading to the poi
being renamed briefly leaky lake anyone
still got full marks after four
questions question 5 the devourer of
worlds chapter 2 gave us a season
dedicated to marvel and the herald of
galactus storyline when the event
started and galactus began walking
towards us what did he say
[Music]
i
hunger
beware i hunger question six batman zero
point batman was pushed into a rift and
came to our island in 2021 he
immediately lost his voice and his
memories went missing too but he still
managed to figure out that by being the
sole survivor in the middle of the final
storm circle made it possible to leave
the loop he really is the greatest
detective ever but here's the question
which character allowed batman to be the
sole survivor by walking into the storm
it was snake eyes from gi joe the two
heroes were able to communicate with
each other by using sign language snake
eyes seemed to believe in batman and
simply walked into the storm destined to
play the same 22-minute fortnite game
forever question 7 sticking with the
comic book run we were hit with some
devastating news fish dix was killed
while assisting batman can you remember
who the killer was
did you get it it was deathstroke he was
working for lex luthor and the batman
who laughs in metropolis who had made a
deal with sloane and io to create rifts
between multiple realities his job was
to trick batman into getting everyone
back home and batman did it question 8
the zero crisis finale gave us a single
player event to play through assisting
the foundation to close tears in reality
and heal the zero point during that
event we randomly changed into many
characters one of those was a character
from a video game who was it
it was lara croft she was a battle pass
skin that season and that event
showcased all the battle class
characters we could buy so lara croft is
officially canon in the storyline of
fortnite back to midas and the device
during the event we somehow transported
into jon jones's office for a short time
in here there were three folders on the
desk can you name the characters on all
three documents
it was midas his daughter jules and the
femme fatale lynx
gj if you got that question 10 ice storm
during chapter 1 season 7 a huge block
of ice connected to the island
as the snow melted here mysterious eggs
were found in polar peak and later in
the volcano which legendary character
did those eggs become
it was the hybrids those weird ninja
dragon people
question 11 rifts chapter 1 season 5 had
an event like no other as items from
inside fortnite were found in the real
world the derberger mascot rifted to the
californian desert whilst it was there a
graffiti artist tagged it and suddenly
he found himself rifted back to the
island we all know him as drift over
that season drift fell in love with a
character
who was it
did you say bright bomber if you did
you're right the pair regularly pop up
in loading screens together and remember
when we found their love carved into a
tree oh the memories question 12. a very
simple question now simply yes or no was
there a live event in chapter two season
one
[Music]
there was live at risky reels was an
event advertising the new star wars
movie we watched the scene we listened
to the director talk and we all had a
fight with some lightsabers the thing
that we really should note though is
that the message spoken by palpatine is
actually canon the broadcast was said to
be heard all over the galaxy which once
again means fortnite is canon in star
wars question 13 operation skyfire saw a
sent onto an alien ship by sloane who
then decided to explode that ship with
us still inside as we made our escape we
ran past the two henchmen can you
remember what room they were stood in
how's your memory
the bromance could be found in a room
filled with alien parasites just waiting
for the moment they popped out of their
little cocoons
we're still not sure what happened to
those dudes that day
maybe we'll find out soon
question 14 the end the following event
after that was the chapter two finale
and the return of the seven the
foundation the scientist and the visitor
all returned to help the loopers the
scientist opened one of the bunker
hatches to get us all into the isle
facility below but how did he open the
hatch do you remember
he used laser orbs and burned through
the metal i totally forgot that was even
a thing in fortnite but it sure is and
if you got this one you may be the
person with the big sprain here question
15 the final showdown the mecca team
leader built all the way back in chapter
one was comprised of five different
parts the head the arms the legs were
all inspired by different characters on
the island can you name all five
characters
[Music]
okay let's go over it the left leg is
tomato head or pizza pit the right is
beef boss or the der burger if you
prefer the right arm represents drift
the left arm is there for rex and of
course the head and torso are there
thanks to the cuddle team leader did you
remember all five when kevin arrived all
the way back in 2018 we watched him roll
around the island until the day he
reached loot lake i want to know what
did kevin do the day he got there
yeah you know this one kevin rolled into
loot lake and dissolved into the water
the wow moment came when suddenly the
entire lake became rubberized like a
trampoline and for the next day or two
the community dubbed the purple water
thanos lake flying around loot lake this
is sick
question 17 back to the device one more
time when we first traveled into
jonesy's office we could hear him
talking to another member of staff
what was her name some of you will get
this right away and others will need
more time and that time is now up when
we first heard johnsy he was talking to
someone called janice stable over here
janice janice uh dial the resonance
actuator to 7.2 now please yes right now
i'm on it
and one day janice will be important i
guarantee it so how did you do 17
questions about the history of fortnite
story and live events i'm thinking about
making this into a trivia series you
down for that i'm adam you're awesome
here's some legends or use my code thank
you very much
[Music]
[Music]